Hello everyone and thank you for taking
the time to join us today.
I'm excited to walk you through our
automated code creation or AQC solution.
Let's dive into how this tool is
transforming the way we manage codes at
CBRE.
At CBRE,
we understand that efficiency and
accuracy are critical to delivering high
quality reports.
Currently,
appraisers must navigate a manual and
time consuming process to cross check and
validate client requirements or crucial
information which can take upto or more
than 45 minutes per report.
This method also introduces the risk of
missed requirements and mix UPS.
A solution uses AI powered automation to
streamline the validation process,
significantly reducing time and
minimizing errors.
With this solution,
we expect to cut the time on each report
substantially.
This not only accelerates our operations,
but also improves accuracy,
reducing the chances of errors or
overlook details.
Ultimately,
this efficient workflow allows appraisers
to focus on higher value tasks,
driving enhanced client satisfaction and
operational performance.
Now let me walk you through how the AQC
tool works in practice.
When an unstructured mail is sent with
key details such as job information,
the originator property information,
and client info,
the AQC tool intelligently extracts these
fields.
Once processed,
the system immediately generates a code
and sends an automatic success
notification back to the user,
which includes the code ID and the
details of successful code creation.
Users can then track code's progress by
accessing the AQC Tracker dashboard.
Using the generated code ID,
they can quickly navigate to the
activation page.
At the activation page,
the system auto populates the Code Basic
task with key information extracted from
the original e-mail.
Users can then modify or update any
details as necessary.
Once this information is verified,
the task can be completed by simply
clicking the Next button.
Upon completion,
all clients information and other
critical details are automatically
updated in the system.
Users can instantly view the status
originator and any other relevant details
of the code,
ensuring everything is accurate and ready
for follow up or next steps.
From May 2024 until now,
AQC has successfully generated 89 quotes,
achieving a success rate of over 70%.
The automation has drastically reduced
the time required for key tasks.
The quote basic task,
which previously took much longer,
is now completed in less than 10 seconds,
while filling in the contact details has
been reduced to almost only one 5.
6 seconds.
The significant reduction in time has
allowed appraisers to focus on more high
value tasks and has minimized the
potential for human errors caused by
manual validation processes.
In summary,
we believe AQC has the potential to
revolutionize code creation processes at
CBRE.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.